ladies and gentlemen I believe the
Oscars are the most important ceremony
in the entire world
oh I don't care about Trump's
impeachment no no I don't care about the
countless environmental disasters we've
been having cool no what matters is that
presumably some white people will win
some great awards and be recognized
Oscar wait screen junkies honest
trailers our friends over there have put
together a video I have been most
anticipated because it's that time of
the year for the Academy Awards honest
trailers the Oscars Tara Eriksen you've
seen every Best Picture nominee I sure
have baby that's right so let's watch
the honest trailers breakdown for us
your friends are John Bailey right I
love John Bailey epic voice okay okay
yeah we're segue whoo
so excited it's time once again for the
Oscars the award show that everyone says
is irrelevant
until the nominations come out based on
a real-life race war wait didn't come
out right
comes the room we'll be watching every
father I love this man - they'd be makes
me hurt again hollering Matt Damon as
racing pioneer Carroll Shelby and
Christian Bale as himself which stars
Ferrari
[Music]
here try this old version of Mary story
instead Kramer flickered both Kramer how
a car V supercar Limbaugh enough justice
from the director yes filming a bag
comes a perilous journey across a world
war one themed Call of Duty bad where
each checkpoint is one of the UK's
hottest hogs yes that's the stuff the
pointless loss of sixteen hundred men or
at least allay their deaths by about a
week tops that's all blended into one
never-ending shot capturing the horrors
of war the chaos of battle and the
desperation of never knowing when it's
okay to go to the bathroom during the
Baja so meticulously crafted that much
like run until part of the way into it
but by then it will be too late to go
back to the beginning and analyze where
the places are that it was stitched
together just sit there conscious of the
fact that it's still going ah get so
used to the fact that there still hasn't
been a cut boys that you forget you were
even looking for one until the very end
some places it's still impressive to do
something that can go on for this long
without losing its entertainment value
the police Batman and the Suicide Squad
but on Oscar night the Joker will face
off against his most powerful nemesis of
all Martin Scorsese in a knockdown
crutch match to determine once and for
all if comic book movies are real cinema
or they're in his words theme parks hope
not not when I take my kids to Joker
World Disorder of the Phoenix nice from
Greta Gerwig boyfriend comes a story
about
erwich's boyfriend's ex-wife own divorce
only this time everyone has to call him
a genius genius and amateur drywall
removal you love white spouse day now
watches Quentin Tarantino changes
history to save old Hollywood yay with
Leonardo DiCaprio as a washed-up star of
dad shows and Brad Pitt as the most
charming alleged white murderer since OJ
these old jobs will foil the Manson
Family killings any minute now
hey there he is
oh no oh yeah wait now we're watching TV
what's going on here summer of 69 it's
been adapted four times for theatres and
even more for television including an
anime
what I got to watch that one
now see ever from the record conahan's
roots a book you are signed in high
school lets you flipped around to the
important bits to cram for an essay in
this classic tale of Little Women and
the even littler boy who's working his
way through them one at a time with the
power initiative it means you don't have
to choose between marriage family and
career as long as a distant relative
dies and leaves you a massive way to
meet his pal Sam Rockwell and rebel
Wilson who put the zan why in NZ I uh
featuring double Oscar nominee Scarlett
Johansson Wow how does she do that it's
gotta be the shoes Hey starring Adolf
Hitler's as you've never seen it before
hilarious if you're looking for laughs
only one movie is the final solution Boy
Meets World War to get ready for a
Korean film about rich people class from
actors Robert DeNiro Joe Pesci Al Pacino
and they're creepy th avatar for an epic
saga exploring the relationship between
the Teamsters Union and organized crime
that you're still working your
because you hear good things about the
Widger looks like wine I'm sure the
second half of the movies disappeared
the first half was just assume it all
ends well for everyone
maybe they even make it back to Ireland
every nice the biggest trends and
festivities this year
inappropriate laughter class divides
hidden rooms cowboys and Indians
precocious kids easy genius you know
release dates getting to a meeting on
time and wait on me and it was traffic
the second idea to attack the line
shortly after dawn tomorrow you think
you can get there in time
Charlie finally arrived two hours late
to pick up Henrietta Colts mother's
house I was hearing actors
Oh white people dancing
[Music]
ah
[Music]
also not storing the following
completely stuffed films thank you some
kind of recognition like these nine yes
[Music]
and you can watch the last forever
[Music]
[Music]
Joker's up were 11 Awards
they'll have to show at least 11 clips
of it no this is a worldwide broadcast
what if people realize they live in a
society by grabthar's hammer what a
trailer in a movie so bad you can
literally never graduate and it wouldn't
make any difference this is just God
real weirdo yeah I sleep with a fan on
every night me too my turret something
to come by this was hysterical this was
truly one of their funniest ones I've
had in a while why don't you go guy in
the other video great job to the writers
that honest trailers the editing was
fantastic John Bailey another epic voice
job especially like the voice they did
on little woman had no idea there was an
animated one hey baby I should watch
that one no it looked creepy you should
not watch it little woman
I gotta say I don't know what it is
about that story I don't know I can't
identify it it has been I just I seen
several versions and I appreciate the
Greta Gerwig one that's actually
probably my favorite one I I've seen of
them so far like the acting is
phenomenal in it I'm not drawn to the
story it's just not for me I've seen a
few versions now just not for me not
even with a quote she says she's like I
don't even care about what she cares
about she's like I just want to be loved
though there are moments like I liked it
I just after for several versions of
this move maybe one day I'll read the
book and I'll be like I get it now but
when I watched the movies I I don't know
I think so she wrote is incredible in
the film towards peers amazing in it - I
like Timothy shallow me I just the whole
thing with Timothy shallow me just that
character you know falling in love with
the two sisters always just reads like
weird and creepy to me anyway he always
loved
first though sorcerer Ronnie's character
before he loved Florence pews character
she denied him still it's whatever
I'm in the minority on this apparently
looks like a really great movie there
jab at Christian Bale playing himself
very true I thought he was incredible in
the movie I like what Christian Bale
actually gets some time to happy a
little bit humorous a little bit comedic
because he's usually so heavy even in
that poem he goes for the heavy
obviously there's so much personality
and he is really funny a lot of the time
actually the Matt Damon is severely
under recognized in that film I think he
gives a really subtle performance which
greatly balances Christian Bale's
performance I think everyone's eyes go
to Christian Bale because he's you know
he's Ken miles he's really loud and
bombastic but Matt Damon I think is just
as good in that movie I think the best
part about that movie where Matt Damon
truly shines is when he goes to talk to
his son at the end of the movie he gives
him the wrench and you can see deep
inside the pain without him saying any
words of recognizing that there's a kid
now without a father
yeah and there is now a wife without a
husband and they weren't like perfect
because they struggled even though his
wife supported 100% in his racing there
was still so many struggles there it
reads all across his face that he's when
he's there in person then it fully
registers what these people are now
going through and what he is also going
through but can't step into bringing
back that part of his life yet because
you both need to grieve separately did
you see 1917 in the theaters or at home
that's not in the theaters hell yeah
that is one of the best movie theatre
experiences I've ever had first off
George McKay's leading performance and
that no one talks about it it should
have been in the conversation for Best
Actor nomination I think everyone looks
at the technical achievement of that
film but George McKay is incredible in
the movie but the editing of it it's so
true like it took me a little bit took
me like 20 minutes before I just settled
and wasn't focused on this whole
one-take illusion that the film was
doing but also a lot of people don't
give the editing credit for that film
because there's so many hidden cuts
throughout it and the whole point of the
editor you're not supposed to notice
when the
cuts were there the editor does such a
great job in every was supposed to look
like one take so why do I considered the
editor for it but their commentary
checking in and out of the movie
wondering about the one take was
definitely consistent for me where I
would start to go wait where do they cut
this how do they do that I would start
to get a little pulled out just because
of the technical achievement that they
they pulled off with it yeah I mean that
whole movie is pre-planned before so
it's already edited before they even
shoot it which is why I recognize that
the editor is like I already know where
I'm gonna make a cut I was distracted in
the first 10 minutes the movie I was
like oh my god they haven't caught they
haven't caught they haven't cut and then
when you recognize there's a blackout
when they first go into the bunker that
eventually blows up and I think that's
the first cut I'm not positive on that
go down through those trenches they
actually time that out to do 362 returns
with the camera with zero cut so they
continue to follow the actors all the
way through that trench which is bonkers
to me we've talked about Joker plenty on
this channel I hope that wins one award
I will add you know a lot of times when
actors are winning a bunch of Awards
they give certain political speeches and
whatnot I think Joaquin Phoenix has been
doing it the absolute best in terms of
making important statements for our
culture society whatever like the one he
just gave in the BAFTA Awards was great
after his environmental speech at the
Golden Globes representing more people
of color at the BAFTA I'm now just
curious to see what he has to say at the
all the Oscars because he's gonna know
what's what's the third thing I always
thanks everyone for dealing with him as
well thank you so much for dealing with
me and I'm like that's how I feel he
always shows up looking like he's drunk
but then he says some of the most
important pro-family stuff Inc in here
yeah parasite Adam all the Best Picture
nominees nineteen seventeen comes close
but parasite gave me so much anxiety
that was a different like I actually
watched it at home on a screener I had
to like get up and like walk around
because it was so intense if you guys
haven't seen parasite you know if you're
not used to watching a foreign language
film trust me you'll be able
watch it you'll be able to settle in
really fast it is it is easily one of
the best movies of the year undoubtedly
the most intense experience I've had out
of any movie that year 1917 comes pretty
close but parasite was like an anxiety
attack with the light at the end shows
such a huge sign where you're like oh
he's a parasite but he's a parasite who
has so much respect for the man whose
house he's living in but that one subtle
move with him just switching the lights
with his head I was like what this is
art man also what came famous is laughs
I just have to say the Joker it's so
good Craig I practiced that I practiced
it I practiced it closed
I pray it was so close got like five
different laughs any of them so close
okay
whatever helps you sleep ah no wait I'll
try one more time like almost dead on
right like you were like walking let's
do a jump cut there a commentary on
marriage story hates the whole movie in
a different life for me I thought that
was Greta Gerwig husband it's her
boyfriend sir boy friend and I didn't
know that it was her boyfriend Noah
Baumbach was doing a story about yeah
yeah and I know she she's like awkward
now she helped him do some of the
writing for it and I know there's like
some release and cathartic experiences
when you get like two writers coming
together where I can understand like the
respect they had for one another for me
I believe it's kind of an awkward thing
that joke though that they had about
everyone's calling him a genius I
thought was just so freakin funny I
think it's great too well asset also
Adam driver help to Noah Baumbach a lot
on that script meaning before he even
wrote the script he talked to Adam
driver because they've worked together
all of the time he's like his top actor
that he chooses and him and added driver
had a big discussion about it cuz Adam
driver has been divorced once and
actually when Scarlett filmed the
marriage story she was going through her
second divorce so it's a bunch of
divorced people being like yeah this
feels right it's not called the it's
called marriage tour the sequel is gonna
be called the merry Irishmen you guys
know how much I love that film I saw it
in the theater is incredible
experience but what they're talking
about very try I've met a lot of people
who either haven't finished it we live
in this weird culture with film and TV
where we'll watch like hours of
television but the thought of sitting
down to watch a 3 1/2 hour movie were
like nah I can binge watch a whole show
and like a day but the thought of
watching a movie for 3 to F hours like
way too long don't want to commit to
that but I guess there's a different
mentality associated cuz when you're
binge watching a lot of times you're not
planning to binge the whole thing you
just end up going yeah sure I'll watch
the next episode guys watch the irishman
if you watch it but also my favorite
moment that I think every lady should
take home a quote from this movie the
Irishman is where he says I chose us
over him and I'm like yeah ladies could
learn from that and then they're like
and then he's like you're gonna have to
beep all those doesn't matter that was
my favorite part of the film where
eventually at the end of the day when
you turn old that you hope that you can
be able to say to someone that you're
like I chose us over him you know unless
him was like super cool and like your
person her soulmate or something but
they won't they won't okay I love that
part in the movie I hope you keep this
in and don't cut it all out you probably
got it oh yeah [ __ ] I think also we can
learn a lot from Scorsese in how to say
come in your everyday life to lead to
more happiness I wrote a blog about that
too okay I'm done talking
thank you honest trailers for putting
this together Thank You Tara for being
you guys check out Tara's blog talking
Tara calm what are you talking about in
that blog oh I talk about a lot of
things like lust love and fun also check
out my youtube channel also I got shown
afterbuzz TV called why aren't you
watching where I pick a new show for you
every week
and I tell you well I don't watch it
there you go Gregory subscribe to screen
junky subscribe to Tara's channel just
drop the real rejects click the
notification bell and it's time for a
patron other days shoutouts
Nissa o liver Anissa my sweetheart you
don't really care to hear from me even
though I'm the one who talks to you all
the time you got a big crush on John so
come on John take down your hair and
shatter out Anissa I just wanted to say
happy 2020 to you thank you for being
here sticking with us you have so much
determination I know you started up your
own channel just recently keep at it
keep dedicated to it make some videos
where you cover us so that we can have
like a symbiotic content feeding
relationship that way if you blow up we
just get even bigger than you can afford
to increase your pledge this is this is
what you like I tried to go with like a
bit of John and a little bit of Greg in
this show this is what you like it what
happens when I don't know anyways you
she apparently doesn't care about me
this is the sexual appeal you got here
how does it is you want some let's do
some some gyrations there oh yeah let's
let's drop it you couldn't live it or
not that's how John actually dances in
public yeah man you know I'm learning to
just loosen up my body that's step one
of dancing said the guy who's not good
at dancing